Can Muslims take the oath of allegiance
to the United States and actually mean
it? I ask because on the one hand,
recent developments seem to question
Islam's place in America. Rightfully so.
On the other hand, these developments
are revealing just how ignorant most
people are about Islam. For example, a
great many Americans continue to make an
artificial distinction between Islam and
Sharia. They see Islam as just another
religion, which is welcome in the United
States, a nation that prides itself on
religious freedom.
Sharia, on the other hand, is seen as
strange, antiquated law codes, loosely
but not necessarily connected to Islam.
Codes upheld only by radical or extreme
Muslims, who represent a minority among
the ummah.
In reality, and as explained in this
video,
Islam and Sharia are inextricably
linked. They are two sides of one coin.
Islam is a descriptive name of the
religion. Sharia is its prescriptive
application. An observant, practicing,
or pious Muslim is by definition a
Sharia-adherent Muslim, which brings me
to the point of this video. This
distinction without a difference
fallacy, undermining how Americans
understand Islam, is just one of their
many blind spots.
A more important, because more
fundamental, blind spot concerns the
oath of allegiance all naturalized
citizens of the United States are
required to take. Most Americans take it
for granted that this oath poses no
difficulties for and can be easily taken
by a people of all or no religions,
including Muslims.
But is that so?
Let's see. Let's go through the oath of
allegiance line by line and compare its
demands on Muslims who want to be US
citizens with Sharia's demands on
Muslims who want to be, well, Muslims.
They who, by definition, surrender to
the will of Allah. The oath of
allegiance to the United States, that
Muslims, like all naturalized US
citizens, must take, begins with these
words, quote, "I hereby declare on oath
that I absolutely and entirely renounce
and abjure all allegiance and fidelity
to any foreign prince, potentate, state,
or sovereignty of whom or which I have
heretofore been a subject or citizen."
Now, as it happens, this opening pledge
directly contravenes one of Islam's most
cardinal rules. Muslims must always be
loyal to and only to fellow Muslims.
This includes Muslim individuals,
groups, entities, and nations. In a
word, the ummah. This important Arabic
word, which means nation, refers to the
supranational Islamic nation that
transcends national identities, borders,
and languages.
Many are the Quran verses and Hadith
that support this position. Quran 5:55
simply informs Muslims that, quote,
"Your only friends and allies are Allah,
his messenger, meaning Muhammad, and
fellow believers." The oath of
allegiance continues, quote, "I hereby
declare on oath that I will support and
defend the Constitution and laws of the
United States of America against all
enemies, foreign and domestic, that I
will bear true faith and allegiance to
the same."
Well,
so now, after pledging that they had
renounced all former allegiances,
Muslims are also required to pledge
their allegiance and support, in a word,
their loyalty to the US and its secular
man-made laws, and to protect the same
against all enemies, including foreign
ones, which naturally includes fellow
Muslims. Once again, this entire pledge
completely contravenes some of Islam's
most core teachings.
Far from being allowed to pledge
allegiance to any non-Muslim person,
entity, or country, Muslims are actually
required, whenever circumstances are
favorable to wage war, jihad, on and
subjugate all non-Muslims, including by,
of course, cooperating with foreign
Muslims,
who as members of the ummah are the only
true brothers of every Muslim, even if
they are of different races, nations,
and languages, as we just saw.
Again, many are the Quran verses that
support this divisive doctrine. Quran
5:51 warns Muslims against,
"taking the Jews and Christians as
friends and allies. Whoever among you
takes them for friends and allies, he is
surely one of them." In other words, any
Muslim who befriends or allies with any
American, Christian, or Jew becomes an
infidel, an enemy of Islam.
There are so many other Quran verses
that promote this sort of religious
tribalism.
Quran 58:22 goes so far as to declare
that true Muslims can never befriend
non-Muslims,  "even if they be
their fathers, sons, brothers, or kin."
Here's a fun fact. According to Islamic
exegesis, several of these verses were
revealed to justify and praise some of
Muhammad's closest companions who
renounced and even slaughtered their own
non-Muslim relatives as a show of their
loyalty to Allah and the believers.
One slew his father, another his
brother, a third, Abu Bakr, the first
caliph, tried to slay his own son, and
Omar, the second caliph, slaughtered
several relatives. Nor is it enough to
reject non-Muslims. The Quran calls on
Muslims to hate all non-Muslims, based
on the example of the prophet Ibrahim,
who is a perversion of the biblical
Abraham. In the Islamic tradition,
before breaking away from his
unbelieving kinsmen, Ibrahim says to
them,  "We renounce you. Enmity
and hate shall forever reign between us
until you believe in Allah alone."
This, the Quran says, is an excellent
example for all Muslims to follow. To
hate all who refuse to submit to Allah.
See Quran 64.
This is why a well-respected cleric
insists that while Muslim men are
permitted to marry and sexually enjoy
Christian and Jewish women, Ahl
al-Kitab, they must also hate and show
that they hate these infidel women. Now,
obviously, most Muslims refuse to admit
before non-Muslims, say fellow
Americans, that this hateful teaching is
actually part of their religion.
The Islamic State is an exception. In an
article titled Why We Hate You and Why
We Fight You, ISIS honestly informed the
West that, quote, "We hate you first and
foremost because you are disbelievers or
infidels." At any rate, here at last we
come to it. Based on everything I've
said so far, and for those who know, all
I've been doing is describing the
mainstream Muslim doctrine of al-wala'
wal-bara', also known as loyalty and
enmity or love and hate for Allah's
sake, based on all this, how can an
observant Muslim take the oath of
allegiance to America?
The answer is simple. Despite its
draconian reputation, Sharia offers
Muslims any number of dispensations,
especially against the infidel,
including the freedom to lie as needed.
Thus, should a Muslim ever find himself
under the authority of non-Muslims, for
instance, as a potential citizen of the
US, he's permitted to swear allegiance
to them, even to the point of cursing
and renouncing Islam. There are ample
historical precedents for this sort of
duplicitous behavior. Quran 3:28 is one
of the most cited verses that justifies
insincere shows of loyalty to
non-Muslims.
It says, quote, "Let believers not take
for friends and allies non-believers
rather than believers. And whoever does
this shall have no relationship left
with Allah unless you but guard
yourselves against them, taking
precautions."
The words translated here as guard and
precaution are derived from the Arabic
word taqqu, which itself forms the root
of the notorious word taqiyya, the
Islamic doctrine that permits Muslims to
deceive non-Muslims whenever under their
authority. Ibn Kathir, author of one of
the most authoritative commentaries on
the Quran, says of this verse, verse
3:28, "quote Whoever at any time or
place fears evil from non-Muslims may
protect himself through outward show."
As proof, he quotes one of Muhammad's
close companions, Abu Darda, who said,
"quote Let us grin in the face of some
people while our hearts curse them."
Muhammad al-Tabari, author of another
celebrated commentary on the Quran,
interprets verse 3:28 by saying, "quote
If you, Muslims, are under their,
non-Muslims, authority, fearing for
yourselves, behave loyally to them with
your tongue while harboring inner
animosity for them.
Know that Allah has forbidden believers
from being friendly or on intimate terms
with non-believers rather than believers
except when the infidels are above them
in authority. Should that be the case,
let them act friendly towards them while
preserving their religion. Incidentally,
and contrary to Islamic apologetics,
Muslims are permitted to deceive
non-Muslims for reasons above and beyond
self-preservation.
They are encouraged, for example, to use
deception, including to the point of
cursing and renouncing Muhammad, to
score a victory against infidels.
Consider the account of the Jewish poet
Ka'b ibn al-Ashraf. According to the
official biographer of the prophet, Ibn
Ishaq, Ka'b insulted Muhammad with his
poetry to the point that Muhammad
exclaimed, "Who will kill this man who
has hurt Allah and his prophet?"
A young Muslim man named Muhammad ibn
Maslama volunteered on condition that in
order to get close enough to assassinate
Ka'b, he be allowed to lie to the poet.
The prophet permitted him to do so.
Ibn Maslama traveled to meet Ka'b and
began to complain about Muhammad until
his disaffection from Islam became so
convincing that Ka'b eventually dropped
his guard and befriended him. He was
convinced he's no longer a follower of
Muhammad.
After behaving as his friend for some
time, Ibn Maslama eventually appeared
with another crypto Muslim.
Then, while a trusting Ka'b's guard was
down, they attacked and slaughtered him,
bringing his head to Muhammad to
triumphant cries of Allahu Akbar.
I think all this goes a long way to
explain how Muslims can easily take the
oath of allegiance to America while in
no way, shape, or form meaning it.
Okay, we've gone on for quite a bit, so
let's end it here. Stay tuned for a
future video. Be sure you're subscribed.
Where we will continue going through the
oath of allegiance because, and believe
it or not, one of its most glaring
contradictions with Islamic teachings is
yet to come. Bring back
Bring back
>> [music]
>> Bring back
>> and the